schön dass Sie da sind guten Tag kommen
sie
setzt sich unsere Mitte
ich habe die Anmoderation jetzt schon
mal übernommen weil unsere Gäste so
diszipliniert sind dass sie meinem
strengen Wunsch sich sofort zu setzen
sofort gefolgt sind ich wollte noch
einen Satz sagen zu diesem Format was
Sie hier sehen das heißt junge Köpfe und
ist eine Talk ein Talk Format das Simon
Strauß mein Kollege aus dem Filter und
ich in Berlin etabliert haben vor
anderthalb Jahren wir laden junge Köpfe
ein aus der Politik aus der Wissenschaft
aus der Wirtschaft aus der Kulturszene
einmal im Monat diskutieren in einem
eigentlich kleineren Rahmen fast schon
ein Salon Charakter in Berlin die Themen
die uns bewegen und heute sind wir hier
auf dem FAZ Kongress und haben ein ganz
besonderen Gast auch einen Jungen Kopf
der mit 36 Jahren jung ist und trotzdem
auf eine
beeindruckende lange und ganz junge
immer relativ ich bin gerade von einer
Mitarbeiterin von ihnen gefragt worden
zu Social Media was ich von tiktok halte
und ich habe dann sagen müssen na ja ich
bin schon einige Generation älter ich
bin noch auf Facebook sozialisiert also
insofern man merkt schon langsam es ist
relativ mitbekommen
so ist es irgendwann aber ich glaube wir
sind trotzdem noch und auch erst recht
Herr Strauß der jüngste in unserer Runde
noch ganz gut dabei Herr kurz ich habe
sie schon vorgestellt wir wollen heute
über Licht und Schatten reden da haben
sie 36 Jahre alt und trotzdem schon
einiges Licht und auch einigen Schatten
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen über
das was sie heute machen was sie damals
gemacht haben und was auf dem Weg
zwischendurch alles passiert ist und
Simon beginnt ja gut wir sind ja hier
auf einem
Medienkongress deswegen vorab ganz
direkt die Frage was bedeuten Ihnen den
Medien persönlich
kommt drauf an ob als Privatperson oder
als als Politiker gesprochen als als
Politiker was ein ein Stück weit immer
ein ein notwendiges Übel als Politiker
verbringt man sehr viel Zeit mit
Kommunikation mit Interviews mit mit dem
sich erklären ist auch der große
Unterschied zu Wirtschaft ich habe jetzt
in meinem wirtschaftlichen Leben auf das
Gefühl es geht darum einfach was zu tun
und fertig in der Politik müssen Sie
erst einmal erklären was sie vorhaben zu
tun dann müssen sie den ganzen Prozess
ständig erklären und besprechen und am
Ende müssen sie dann rechtfertigen oder
erklären was sie getan haben und warum
was okay ist in einer Demokratie aber es
ist natürlich ein ein ein starker
Zeitaufwand für ein Politiker ich glaube
eine Herausforderung die ich sehe auch
jetzt als Privatperson ist dass ich den
Eindruck habe es gibt in jedem Land
insbesondere auch kleineren Ländern wie
Österreich dann doch einen relativ engen
meinungskorridor also wir haben zwar
eine gewisse
Medienvielfalt aber ich würde sagen die
Mainstream Meinung ist dann doch relativ
klar definiert und wird einmal von sehr
sehr vielen Medien und vielen
Journalisten dann doch am Ende des Tages
oftmals einheitlicher getragen als mir
das lieb wäre und der dritte Gedanke zu
den zu den zu den
nur wenige die nicht im Mainstream sind
anscheinend und
der dritte Gedanke der der mir kommt ist
dass ich glaube das Social Media sehr
viel verändert hat also insbesondere für
uns in unserer politischen Zeit
Österreich ist ein kleines Land knapp 9
Millionen Menschen wir haben am Ende des
Tages über eine Million Menschen direkt
per Social Media erreicht und konnten
sozusagen direkt mit der Bevölkerung
kommunizieren was was extrem bereichernd
war nicht nur weil man teilweise
ungefilter da haben wir die Möglichkeit
hat zu sagen wofür man steht sondern
auch in die andere Richtung weil die
Bevölkerung wesentlich aktiver direkt
auch Feedback geben konnte zum zweiten
Punkt machen Sie das fest also das
sozusagen der berühmte gelb größer wird
zwischen der veröffentlichten und der
öffentlichen Meinung
kannst versuchen es mit Einzelbeispielen
zu untermauern aber ich glaube das dass
es in vielen Sachfragen Möglichkeiten
gibt die Dinge unterschiedlich zu sehen
und ich habe das Gefühl dass diese
breite dann nicht immer in der
Berichterstattung stattfindet und bei
mir wird sehr stark dieses Empfinden
getriggert durch das massive unterwegs
sein jetzt den anderen Teilen der Welt
es gibt viele Länder das Atomstrom etwas
völlig Selbstverständliches und es gibt
kaum kritische Stimmen in Österreich
wird mir kein einziger einfallen
vielleicht gibt's den einen oder anderen
gibt es nicht wahrgenommen dass ich für
Atomstrom aussprechen würde in der
medialen Berichterstattung das ist jetzt
nur ein kleines Beispiel aber aber es
zeigt doch dass es sozusagen in in
weiten oder oftmals sozusagen sehr
verbreitet ist das in gewissen Gegenden
in gewissen Regionen in gewissen Staaten
ein gewisser meinungskorridor vorhanden
ist in spielt sich die öffentliche
Debatte ab und links und rechts oben und
unten davon gibt es dann oft relativ
wenig haben sie als Politiker das Gefühl
gehabt persönlich dass sie ungerecht
behandelt worden sind von Medien ja
natürlich aber ich glaube jeder jeder
Mensch ist subjektiv und ich glaube
sogar Politiker die jetzt da
linkeren Parteien angehören und
vielleicht sozusagen medial besser
behandelt werden fühlen sich auch noch
ungerecht behandelt also insofern ist es
einmal immer ein ein subjektives Gefühl
dass man sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt
aber
ich würde mal sagen sozusagen das jetzt
nicht alle Journalisten
Wähler rechts damit sind
ist wahrscheinlich etwas was man zwar
nicht aussprechen darf aber es ist
trotzdem falsch es ist interessant weil
sie doch auf der anderen
interessant weil auf der anderen Seite
sind sie ja doch am Anfang ihrer
Karriere jedenfalls nach meiner Warnung
ziemlich hochgeschrieben worden
sind zu jung um das Miterleben zu haben
vielleicht
also ich bin damals mit 24
Staatssekretär geworden und es ist
damals im Standard im österreichischen
oder im Profil ich war nicht mehr in
einem der Qualitätsmedien in Österreich
ist gestanden seine Verarsche dass da
jemand mit 24 20 sekretiert wird ein
anderes Medium hat auf der Titelseite
gehabt so viel verdient und das ist sein
dienstaut und sogar der einzige bei dem
was passiert waren ist weil für die eine
Regierung alle gleich viel also insofern
ich hatte nicht das Gefühl dass ich so
so groß willkommen geheißen worden bin
damals und schon verändert es hat sich
verändert aber der Wiener Einsatz sagen
was ich sehr spannend fand damals und
ich glaube das ist auch ein bisschen ein
Problem
unserer Zeit wir haben
wir haben die Situation dass durch
online Medien und insbesondere durch
Social Media sich Informationen
innerhalb von wenigen Minuten auf der
ganzen Welt verbreiten lassen ganz eine
andere Situation als früher und
gleichzeitig wissen sie besser als ich
haben wir die Situation das in vielen
Medienhäusern die Budgets knapper werden
und jetzt weniger Budget für echte
journalistische Arbeit und Recherche zur
Verfügung steht und das führt wiederum
dazu dass natürlich auch jegliche
falsche Information innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit verbreitet werden kann
ein lustiges Beispiel aus aus meiner
Zeit jetzt kann ich darüber lachen
damals habe ich es nicht so lustig
gefunden als ich 24 waren Staatssekretär
wurde ich komme eigentlich aus ganz
normalen Verhältnissen meine Mutter ist
Lehrerin mein Vater war Mitarbeiter in
einem ist Ingenieur und war Mitarbeiter
in einem großen Betrieb bin ganz normal
aufgewachsen in einem Arbeiter Bezirk in
in Wien war mein Leben lang in
öffentlichen Schulen also wir waren
weder arm noch wohlhabend einfach eine
sehr normale Familie und dass ich
Staatssekretär wurde mit 24
ist in mehreren Zeitungen damals
erschienen das Sebastian Kurz ist eben
aufgewachsen im nobel Bezirk Hietzing da
wie in meinem ganzen Leben noch nie
gelebt war auf Privatschulen ist mit dem
goldenen Löffel im Mund aufgewachsen in
einer reichen Industriellen Familie und
das Thema Integration für dass ich
damals zuständig war kennt er nur
aufgrund des Dienstpersonals und das
Haus Personals das Migrationshintergrund
hatte und das war in mehreren Medien und
noch heute sprechen mich Leute wenn ich
in Hietzing spazieren gehe nobel Bezirk
wo noch immer in Meidling im Arbeiter
Bezirk sondern noch immer manchmal Leute
zu mir ja schön sie wohnen ja auch bei
uns in Hietzing und ich denke immer
herzlich jetzt 15 Jahre gehalten ja
bei der FAZ sind wo knallhart
recherchiert wird und keine Fehler
vielleicht schon mal passieren aber
ich glaube sowas stand bei uns nicht
also das ist dann eine Frage der
Definition da das führt jetzt zu weit
jetzt geht es darum Herr kurz dass ja
Kollegen von uns vom Spiegel heute
morgen eine Schlagzeile veröffentlicht
haben die sie vielleicht noch nicht alle
gesehen haben und ich lese sie einmal
kurz vor Korruptionsverdacht gegen
Sebastian Kurz weitet sich aus die
Meldung ist von gestern Abend hat sich
heute früh verbreitet und auch weil wir
natürlich gerne auch Talker sind und so
weiter aber am Ende natürlich knallharte
recherchieren Journalisten sind freuen
uns dass Sie hier sind und direkt
Stellung nehmen können zu diesem Vorwurf
vielleicht erklären Sie einmal kurz aus
dann gucken gleich wenn wir mal ab ähm
was aus ihrer Sicht eigentlich der
Vorhof ist
ich muss dazu sagen ich bin subjektiv
aber begonnen begonnen hat alles mit
einem Vorwurf dass ich in einem
parlamentarischen urschuss die
Unwahrheit gesagt hätte wobei wir wollen
jetzt mal den medienfokus nehmen weil
wir ja ja
sie haben mich gefragt ich versuche
wahrheitsgetreu zu schildern
da ist der Vorwurf
dass ich auf eine Frage die ein nie
enthalten habe mit einem nah geantwortet
habe und jetzt wird diskutiert ob er
eine das eine doppelte Verneinung eine
Bejahung oder doch ein Widerspruch sein
ich habe einmal in dieser vierstündigen
Einvernahme eine passive Formulierung
verwendet
es gab Gespräche das jetzt die Frage
damit gemeint sein dass ich in den
Gesprächen dabei war oder nicht und
insofern gibt es jetzt seit zwei Jahren
Ermittlungen ob ich in diesem
parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss
die Unwahrheit gesagt hat und dann gibt
es ein zweites Verfahren da wird
vorgeworfen dass
das
Meinungsforschung betrieben worden wäre
mit gelderndes Finanzministeriums aber
zum Vorteil meiner Partei muss dazu
sagen ich war nie Finanzminister ich war
in der Zeit in der das stattgefunden
haben soll nicht mal Bundesparteiobmann
oder Bundeskanzler und diese jetzt auch
ausgeweitet worden auf Inserate die
illegal
vergeben werden hätten sollen wenn sie
mich nach meiner persönlichen Meinung
fragen ich weiß was ich gemacht habe in
meinem Leben und was nicht
befürchten dass Sie hier gleich
abgeführt werden also alles ist möglich
aber
also insofern
insofern
drei ich mich nichts mehr verhersagen
aber vielleicht nachdem jetzt nicht alle
deutschen das wahrscheinlich im Detail
mitverfolgen als Betroffener ist es
natürlich manchmal etwas etwas
mühsam früher in der Politik hat mich
mehr betroffen als jetzt ist immer so
ein wichtiger Bestandteil meines Lebens
aber ich habe schon das Gefühl dass wir
ein rechtsstaatliches Problem damit
haben das Vorwürfe in den Raum gestellt
werden das jahrelang darüber medial
berichtet wird und wenn sich dann
herausstellt dass diese Vorwürfe falsch
waren dann ist das nur eine Kurzmeldung
im Fall von Österreich in den
im Fall von Österreich lassen sich den
Gedanken nur zu Ende führen gab es
dutzende Vorwürfe die in den letzten
Jahren erhoben worden sind vor allem
gegen auch Mitglieder meiner Partei
nicht nur und wissen Sie was all die
Vorwürfe bisher gemeinsam haben in all
den Vorwürfen die erhoben worden sind in
den letzten Jahren die bisher vor
Gericht gelandet sind gab es immer
Einstellungen oder Freisprüche es gab
keine einzige Verurteilung bisher es ist
aber ein Thema das Österreich medial
seit Jahren massiv Projekt welches
gelassen und gleichzeitig ein Stück weit
problematisch da müssen wir noch mal
einhaken und zwar der Vorwurf ist ja um
das noch mal zu sagen schon sehr
ungeheuerlich nämlich nicht nur das
Inserate vom Finanzministerium bezahlt
worden sind sein also mit Steuergeld
sondern auch dass Umfragen frisiert
worden sein also tatsächlich Umfragen
erstellt wurden z.B was hält man von
politischen Islam und anderen Themen die
sie damals gesetzt haben als sie kurz
davor waren Bundeskanzler zu werden
und dann der Vorwurf ist und das ist ja
nicht nur der Vorwurf sondern auch es
gibt 300.000 Chats die ausgewertet
wurden von
einem Herrn Thomas Schmid und der aus
den sich die Ermittler sagen also und
das ist eben heute noch ausgeweitet
worden also quasi das gesamte
österreichische Boulevard hat kooperiert
mit ihrem Team und habe so der Vorwurf
eben unfragen zu ihren Gunsten
gefälscht also sprich wir reden hier von
einem klassischen Fake News der zwar
Journalisten Seite war aber so der
Vorwurf von Politiker Seite initiiert
worden ist und jetzt frage ich mich wenn
ich das so höre dann muss ja eine Seite
muss ja also entweder wie sie sagen an
den Vorwürfen ist gar nichts dran dann
frage ich mich was ist los mit der
Justiz in Österreich ist das ein derart
vor rotes System dass wir im Grunde von
einem Rechtsstaat nicht mehr sprechen
können also waren sie mal Bundeskanzler
eines Landes in dem die fundamentalen
Grundsätze der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
nämlich ordentlich zu ermitteln
das würde mich schockieren
sie sagen es ist so also es wird sie
sagen
aber Österreich ist eigentlich erfüllt
die Grundsätze weil ich ich bin ich bin
jemand der immer gern möglichst sachlich
bleibt ja insofern insofern reden wir
nicht über die ganze Justiz ja weil die
Justiz ist sozusagen ein sehr weiter und
und breiter Begriff es ist eine Behörde
die Wirtschafts- und
Korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft es ist
eine Behörde die in den letzten Jahren
mehrere Verfahren gestartet hat die
bisher alle mit Freisprüchen oder
Einstellungen geändert haben zuletzt
waren über zehn Personen vor Gericht und
in der Anklageschrift sind sogar die
Funktionsbezeichnungen falsch
niedergeschrieben worden ein Politiker
ist als Stadtrat bezeichnet worden
obwohl er in überhaupt nicht Stadtrat
war sondern Abgeordnete und am Ende des
Tages war monatelang in den Medien am
Ende des Tages sind alle angesprochen
worden und nicht nur das sondern der
Richter hat sogar gesagt also hat offen
die Behörde kritisiert es gibt
rechtsschutzbeauftragte die offen das
Vorgehen kritisiert haben und wenn sie
den Vergleich zu Deutschland ziehen ich
kann nur sagen in Deutschland wäre das
unmöglich ich bin gestern beschuldigt
worden und wissen Sie wie ich es wieder
mal erfahren habe aus den Medien ich
habe von Journalisten vorher
Informationen bekommen bevor ich
überhaupt als Beschuldigter die
Dokumente zugestellt bekommen habe
naja also sozusagen man kann immer
darüber lachen ja aber einen ein Gedanke
man kann darüber lachen aber wenn wir
sozusagen schon von recht statt reden
und unsere Standards hochhalten wollen
dann möchte ich nur sagen der eine große
Unterschied und der stimmt rein
rechtlich wäre das was in Österreich
stattfindet nämlich die
Berichterstattung aus Verfahren bevor es
ein Urteil gibt das wäre ein rechtlich
so in Deutschland überhaupt nicht
möglich und undenkbar sie könnten
niemals tun weil es verboten ist in
Deutschland und das zweite ist dass ich
schon den Eindruck habe dass einfach die
Justiz hier leider Gottes missbraucht
wird um Politik zu machen und das halte
ich für eine problematische Entwicklung
und ein letzter Satz wenn am Ende des
Tages genauso oft über den Freispruch
berichtet wird wie vorher über die
Vorwürfe dann ist ja alles in Ordnung
den Deal würde ich sofort akzeptieren es
ist nur leider oft nicht so noch einen
letzten Punkt der Richterbund hat ja
mehrfach auch ihnen vorgeworfen das
Vertrauen in die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
durch solche Aussagen die sie auch jetzt
hier getätigt haben zu unterminieren
also der Rechtsstaat lebt natürlich auch
davon dass wir vertrauen ihm
entgegenbringen und wenn man auf der
Bühne sitzt und sagt eigentlich ist
unsere Justiz politisiert und lässt sich
instrumentalisieren von einer Partei
sehen sie da nicht auch eine Gefahr oder
würden Sie einfach sagen Österreich ist
so es ist so verrot und wir müssen uns
jetzt vielleicht mal an Ursula von der
Leyen wenden die auch schon mal hier war
dass sie vielleicht auch in Österreich
mal genauer hinguckt und den rechts
staatsmechanismus in Gang setzt naja
schauen Sie ich glaube ich glaube
versuchen wir es einfach auf Fakten zu
reduzieren ja
in Österreich gibt es eine gesetzliche
Grundlage des Anklagen stattfinden
sollen wenn eine
verurteilungswahrscheinlichkeit von über
50 Prozent vorliegt die Wirtschafts- und
Korruption Staatsanwaltschaft hat in den
letzten Jahren definitiv definitiv nicht
über 50% der Verfahren in diesem
politischen Kontext gewonnen sondern sie
hat null gewonnen und alle verloren
kann man die Frage stellen sozusagen ist
das rechtmäßig also entspricht zumindest
nicht dem was vorgesehen ist das zweite
ist
es gibt schon sehr eindeutige
Beschuldigten Rechte und ganz klare
Regelungen was im Gerichtssaal statt zu
finden hat und was in den Medien
stattfinden hat dass es hier ständig
liegt und das ist so zu einer medialen
Vorverurteilung kommt ist auch
rechtswidrig es ist sogar strafrechtlich
relevant es ist schwer nachzuweisen aber
sozusagen das
das hier Informationen in den Medien
diskutiert werden die eigentlich vor
Gericht diskutiert werden sollen ist
auch ein Faktum und dann könnte man das
da rein auch weiter diskutieren insofern
bin immer Politiker darum ist es nicht
mein Job mich damit zu beschäftigen aber
ich habe in den letzten Jahren meine
Erfahrungen gemacht und kann Ihnen nur
sagen ich hatte schon den Eindruck dass
mit mehr und mehr Erfolg bei den Wahlen
es dazu gekommen ist dass einmal mehr
und mehr politische Gegner auf Anzeigen
Vorwürfe Unterstellungen gesetzt haben
die teilweise auch in Verfahren gemündet
haben und ich persönlich bin sehr
gelassen weil ich bin jung genug dass
ich eine Entscheidung erleben werde und
ich bin mir einfach sicher dass das gut
ausgehen wird und insofern ja wird wird
es für mich eine persönliche Genugtuung
sein und das in mehr und mehr Ländern
nicht nur in Österreich waren wenn ich
zu tun als wäre es ein österreichisches
Phänomen
Vorwürfe Skandale Unterstellungen
Verfahren die dann vielleicht am Ende
des Tages im Sand verlaufen ein Tool in
der zumindest parteipolitischen
Auseinandersetzung geworden sind das ist
ihnen ja sicher nicht entgangen nein ich
finde nur das nicht Aufgabe der Justiz
und eine robuste Justiz muss ich jeder
jeden versuchen politischer
Einflussnahme widersetzen das ist
geradezu dass Merkmal von
Rechtsstaatlichkeit da bleiben wir dran
sind kommen wir vielleicht mal zu der
generelleren Frage der medialen
Beeinflussung durch sie durch Sie selbst
oder durch ihr Team ich meine ihr
langjähriger Presse Sprecher der auch
angeklagt ist Herr Fleischmann hat ein
Buch gerade veröffentlicht message
control ja also die Vorstellung dass man
Medien eigentlich wirklich kontrollieren
muss das ist ja erstmal auch legitim
jede politische Partei versucht das aber
da sind ja genau die Vorwürfe auch dass
durch Inseraten Käufe da positive
Berichterstattung
initiiert worden ist lassen wir das mal
ein Moment mal sagt und fokussieren uns
einen Fakten sie haben ja gesagt wir
wollen uns auf die Fakten konzentrieren
interessanter Fall fand ich im Juni 2018
hat ein Kommentar der Kommentator der
Financial Times sie als äußerst rechten
Kanzler bezeichnet gegen diese
Bezeichnung haben Sie dann über die
österreichische Botschaft in Washington
intervenieren lassen das haben Sie ja
selbst zugegeben wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe im EU optisches des
Nationalrats was stört Sie denn an der
Bezeichnung rechts eigentlich
stört mich an der Bezeichnung überhaupt
nichts aber es gibt glaube ich trotzdem
mittlerweile und das hat sich hier
herumgesprochen haben ein
Parteienspektrum in der Europäischen
Union und das Parteienspektrum ist
relativ eindeutig es gibt
Sozialdemokraten es gibt grüne es gibt
Linksparteien es gibt Christdemokraten
und es gibt rechts Parteien und wenn
jetzt jemand mich einem rechten Blog
zuordnet obwohl ich seit meinem 16
Lebensjahr Mitglied einer
christdemokratischen Partei bin ist es
einfach falsch ja also es ist ja keine
Intervention sondern einfach ein Fehler
Punkt ja also würde christlich
konservativ bezeichnen oder wie wäre
ihre Ausweis
ich meine ich war immerhin Partei Chef
einer christdemokratischen Partei ich
war Chef der Jugendorganisation einer
christdemokratischen Partei ähm also
welche Eigenschaften würden sie
festmachen mit dem Begriff christlich
konservativ
sozusagen bleiben wir noch mal bei Ihrer
Fragen da geht es ja nicht um die Frage
ob jemand der Meinung ist dass ich sein
der Meinung nach rechts oder links bin
soll jeder möchte sondern es gibt
Parteien ja es gibt auf europäische
Ebene Parteien und
da eine falsche Einordnung zu treffen
ist einfach ein Fehler ja ich kann jetzt
auch sagen wenn ich die Arbeiten nicht
bei der FHZ sondern bei der Süddeutschen
und dann werden Sie sagen hallo hallo
ist in Ordnung ich habe nichts gegen die
Süddeutsche aber es ist eine andere ein
anderes Medium so und und ich finde das
ist der absolut legitim dass man an
Journalisten ja die machen nie Fehler
aber wenn doch mal ein Fehler passiert
darauf Hinweis dass ein Fehler war ja
dass man über die Botschaft interveniert
ist eine andere Sache noch mal ganz kurz
aber
dafür interessieren
weil über das Wort intervenieren wenn
wenn ich als Politiker oder als
Privatperson oder als
wirtschaftstreibender der Meinung bin es
ist etwas falsch dann werde ich ja
darauf hinweisen dürfen das falsch ist
das könnte doch schwer schreiben ich
heiße Alexander würde ich auch sagen
entschuldigung aber was ist
ein rechter Politiker waren sie haben
eine rechte Flüchtlingspolitik gemacht
z.B sie haben das ist reden
das ist ja alles in Ordnung mir ging es
um die Einordnung wenn ich als
Christdemokrat einer Rechtspartei zu
fördert wird dann ist das eine falsche
Einordnung und dann können wir gerne
darüber reden ist nur eine Politik
rechts oder links oder was auch immer
ich habe sie immer als relativ normal
und mittig empfunden ich bin bin
definitiv kein Linker und und und
insofern wenn sie mich einordnen wollen
dann würde ich sagen eher als Mitte
rechts als etwas anderes ich habe auch
die Erfahrung gemacht und das fand ich
eigentlich am spannendsten dass viele
Ansichten zunächst als rechtsradikal
abgetan wurden bis man dann drauf
gekommen ist es ist eigentlich richtig
und mehr und mehr diese Positionen
geteilt haben Stichwort
Flüchtlingspolitik als wir im Jahr 2015
das erste mal gesagt haben wir brauchen
eine Steuerung der Migrationspolitik es
dürfen nicht die Schlepper entscheiden
wer zu uns kommt sondern es müssen die
Staaten und die Europäische Union
entscheiden wer zu wandert ist das
abgetan worden als als
rechtsradikal ähm kurze Zeit später hat
Deutschland selbst entschieden die
Grenzen schließen zu müssen weil es
einfach nicht mehr ging und mittlerweile
verfolge ich dass viele der Sätze die
ich damals gesagt habe mittlerweile von
liberalen Sozialdemokraten und anderen
Politikern in fast
genauso
gesprochen werden kann ich einmal noch
mal nachfragen zur Asylpolitik
2015 und heute
2015 und heute würden sie da ein
Unterschied machen syrische christlichen
kriegspflüchtlinge ukrainische
kriegsflüge ja sicher weil
beide Situationen nicht miteinander
vergleichbar sind sie sagen jetzt
syrische Flüchtlinge aber ich habe die
Zahlen von 2015 noch sehr gut im Kopf
das waren nicht nur Syrer die zu uns
gekommen sind sondern es waren Menschen
aus unterschiedlichsten Ländern sie
hatten die Gemeinsamkeit dass viele
angegeben haben sie sein aus Syrien aber
es hat nicht bei allen zugetroffen ein
zweiter Aspekt ist ähm wenn sie sich die
flüchtlingsstruktur jetzt anschauen ob
du Ukraine dann sind das sehr sehr oft
Familien sehr oft Frauen sehr oft Frauen
mit Kindern und soweit ich weiß in den
seltensten Fällen Alleinreisende junge
Männer
und zum dritten erleben Sie ja jetzt
schon dass viele der Menschen sofort
sobald möglich ist oder Perspektive
besteht versuchen auch wieder in die
Ukraine zurückzukehren das heißt ich
würde sagen von meiner Wahrnehmung aus
würde ich die zwei Szenarien nicht
unbedingt vergleichen wir haben damals
die Situation gehabt dass sie einfach
sehr sehr viele Menschen auf den gemacht
haben und das durch die
willkommenspolitik und und durch das
Erwecken des Eindrucks jeder sei in
Europa will kommen und würde
freundlichster Bahnhof begrüßt werden
und dann sozusagen
wäre man froh je mehr kommen desto
besser ich glaube dass das schlicht und
ergreifend extrem problematisch war weil
es viele Menschen einfach dazu
veranlasst hat sich auf den Weg zu
machen die Schlepper und Summen dabei
verdient haben und was das zügigste und
problematischste dabei ist auch diese
massive migrationsbewegung zu unzähligen
Toten im Mittelmeer geführt hat weil je
mehr Menschen sich auf den Weg gemacht
haben je mehr Schlepper diese Not auch
missbraucht haben dass du mehr Menschen
sind auch im Mittelmeer damals ertrunken
wir halten fest die differenzieren
zwischen ukrainischen Flüchtlingen und
syrischen flüchten nein ich würde mal
würde mal ganz grundsätzlich
differenzieren zwischen Flüchtlingen und
Wirtschaftsmigranten ist glaube ich
einmal ein erster wichtiger Punkt das
heißt nicht dass nicht die Not der
Menschen verstehe ich verstehe jeden der
ein wirtschaftlich schlechten
Verhältnissen lebt und sich auf den Weg
macht um anderswo ein besseres Leben
führen zu können ich kann das menschlich
zu 100% nachvollziehen ich glaube nur
dass wir als Staaten in Europa trotzdem
die Verantwortung haben eine Steuerung
zu treffen und nicht Schlepper
entscheiden zu lassen wer durchkommt und
wer nicht durchkommt und wir haben
damals schlicht und ergreifend und auch
heute noch die Situation ist einfach die
Masse der Menschen die sich auf den Weg
macht sie nicht die Ärmsten der Armen
sind nicht notgedrungen die die aus
Kriegsgebieten kommen sondern sind
Menschen die genug Geld haben um den
Schlepper zu finanzieren es können viele
aus den ärmsten Ländern Afrikas nämlich
gar nicht mal stemmen und zum zweiten
sind oft junge Männer die sich auf den
Weg machen und und insofern habe ich
eine sehr klare Meinung zur Migration
und seitdem ich in anderen Teilen der
Welt sehr viel unterwegs bin hat sich
diese Meinung nicht abgeschwächt sondern
sie hat sich eigentlich verst ärkt weil
ich kaum ein anderes entwickeltes
wohlhabendes Land außerhalb Europas
bisher angetroffen habe dass das einfach
über sich ergehen lässt andere Länder
Steuern Migration ganz massiv
da hat sich in Deutschland die Debatte
natürlich tatsächlich auch verändert wir
wollen noch auf ein wichtiges Thema
kommen und ja gerne auch mit ihnen noch
ein wenig diskutieren das Thema Russland
gestern hat sich im
österreichischen Parlament etwas
zugetragen dass sie auch heute in
unserer Zeitung lesen konnten nämlich
ihre ehemaliger Koalitionspartner FPÖ
hat den Raum verlassen hat Schilder
hinterlassen auf den Stand Platz für
Frieden als
kein falscher Eindruck entstehen als der
ukrainische Präsident für ein Statement
in das Parlament zugeschaltet worden ist
wie finden sie so einfach halten
also ich sage Ihnen meine Meinung und
ich ergänze ein paar Fakten erstens ich
habe schon wieder ein Parteien
kontrolliert zweitens es war auch die
Hälfte der sozialen Koalitionspartner
genauso wie die Grünen genau
die Hälfte der Sozialdemokratie war
nicht im Saal
und drittens ich persönlich finde es
nicht gut klarerweise ich habe hier
einen anderen Zugang und auch die die
Volkspartei der ich angehöre hat hat
hier einen anderen Zugang in Summe
glaube ich
ist die österreichische Situation
trotzdem eine etwas andere als in
Deutschland unabhängig jetzt von diesem
Verhalten und und das das Stimmungsbild
in Österreich eine etwas anderes
aufgrund unserer Neutralität aufgrund
unserer Geschichte gibt sie glaube ich
eine etwas andere Prägung und auch eine
etwas andere wahrscheinliche öffentliche
debatteis in Deutschland ja wollen wir
darüber reden über ihren Blick sie haben
gerade also ihre Haltung wie sie gesagt
haben zu Russland sie haben ein Buch
geschrieben das ist im vergangenen Jahr
erschienen das heißt ähm reden wir über
Politik und da beschreiben Sie ein
Treffen mit oder mehrere treffen die sie
mit Wladimir Putin hatten sie schreiben
überhaupt relativ viel über Russland
über russische Sicherheitsinteressen die
sie unter anderem durch die
EU durch die nato-ost-erweiterung
bedroht sehen mir ist aufgefallen dass
sie relativ wenig über die Ukraine
schreiben waren sie eigentlich mal haben
sie die Ukraine als Kanzler besucht naja
unzählige Male viele Freunde dort und
das dann zu diesem Eindruck also in
Deutschland gibt es ja nicht nur damit
verbunden mit dem Wort Zeitenwende
sondern gibt es ja eine Stimmung
dass man auf die eigene Geschichte
insbesondere Geschichte der
Sozialdemokratie aber auch die Union hat
ihre Hausaufgaben zu machen schaut und
da ist ja insbesondere der
entscheidende Punkt nach zwei 14 die
Annexion der Krim die
völkerrechtswidrige wo heute jedenfalls
in Deutschland würde ich sagen die
vorher schon eine Meinung besteht man
hätte damals sehr viel schärferantworten
müssen und Putin zu zeigen dass es dass
er so nicht weitergehen kann also er
versteht nur die die die Stimme der der
Stärke möglicherweise sogar der Waffen
sie haben und das finde ich interessant
in ihrem Buch folgenden Satz geschrieben
es sei unredlich so zu tun als hätte uns
eine andere
Politik den Krieg erspart also sie sehen
es genau anders dass man im Grunde
diesen Krieg gar nicht verhindern konnte
und in der Vergangenheit im eigentlich
alles richtig gelaufen ist das haben sie
da richtig verstanden
darf ich
[Musik]
würde sagen es ist relativ komplex ja
also ich
war 2014 Außenminister als
damit Darmstadt gefunden hat wer war wir
waren damals als Österreich
oscd-vorsitzender ich war mitten in der
Ukraine sondern damals auch schon im
Osten der Kräne und
habe
das alles sehr genau mitverfolgt in
vielen Gesprächen mit ukrainischen
Politikern und damals auch in vielen
Kontakten mit Wladimir Putin und anderen
anderen Vertretern Russlands ich habe in
den in der Zeit in das Buch entstanden
ist auch ein Stück weit die deutsche
Debatte mitverfolgt und und viel Kritik
an Angela Merkel dass ihre Russland
Politik betrifft und ähm das habe ich
aufgegriffen und genauso wie ich mit
Angela Merkel in der Flüchtlings und
Migrationspolitik in den Jahren 2015 und
folgende nie einer Meinung war genauso
finde ich persönlich das dass ihr hier
Unrecht getan wird und schlicht und
ergreifend die Meinung dass wir nicht
wissen welches Verhalten des Westens
wozu geführt hätte es gibt diejenigen
die sagen hätten wir in den Jahren 2014
und folgende wesentlich aggressiver auf
Russland reagiert hätten wir
grundsätzlich wesentlich weniger
Schnittmengen noch ein wirtschaftlichen
Bereich oder
energiepolitischen Bereich mit Russland
dann wäre dieser Konflikt gar nicht erst
eingetreten und
andere wiederum sagen hätten wir mehr
auf Dialog gesetzt hätten wir vielleicht
die russischen Interessen mehr
berücksichtigt hätten wir Russland
stärker in gewisse Überlegungen und
Diskussionen integriert dann wäre uns
der Konflikt erspart geblieben und meine
These schlicht und ergreifend dass ich
es nicht weiß ich habe all das sehr
genau mitverfolgt ich kenne alle Handeln
Akteure persönlich und ich
so leicht mir tut aber ich habe keine
abschließende Meinung dazu sich
persönlich für richtige achten aber ihre
Handlung war ja schon klar gerichtet auf
Dialog auf wirtschaftliche Verflechtung
also ich erinnere nur 218 haben sie oder
hat eine teilstaatliche Gesellschaft
einen großen Vertrag mit Gazprom
abgeschlossen da sitzt es gibt ein Foto
das ist Alex in Miller mit dem
österreichischen Vertreter des
Unternehmens und sie und Vladimir Putin
stehen im Hintergrund und dieser Vertrag
dieser gaslieferungsvertrag in großen
Stil sollte bis 2040 laufen also wurde
noch mal verlängert es gibt die Hochzeit
ihrer damaligen Außenministerin mit ich
wollte wo sie mit Wladimir Putin getanzt
hat und all diese Dinge also man hat
schon den Eindruck sie haben klar diese
auf diese Verpflichtung gesetzt glauben
Sie nach wie vor dass das dieses Wandel
durch Handel oder Wandel durch
Verpflichtung funktioniert hätte mit
diesem Russland mit diesem Putin werden
wie wir ihn jetzt kennen also sie
stellen solange Fragen dass ich bei dem
Zusammenhang vergessen Hochzeit weil es
geht einfach ich habe nicht geheiratet
ich habe nicht mal getanzt ja und die
die Dame die mit dem russischen
Präsidenten getanzt hat ist nicht von
meiner Partei also insofern
Koalitionspartner
vorher schon gehabt dass ich mit
sie finden niemals den perfekten
Koalitionspartner ja es ist immer es ist
immer ein Kompromiss ja
solange man so gut mit sich selbst kann
braucht man nicht vielleicht ja auch
nicht ja aber aber schauen Sie ich
glaube zum Thema
über das eigene Handeln und Denken Rede
und Antwort zu stehen weil ich weiß
nicht wie sie das Spiel in Deutschland
spielen aber wenn sie in Deutschland
jetzt im Urlaub Scholz vorwerfen was die
CDU denkt und dann sagt aber es gab mal
eine Koalition zwischen CDU und SPD also
kann man machen ist nur glaube ich
kompliziert meine Meinung und und die
gibt der Mann sucht sich sein Kollektion
aus aber wir lassen uns jetzt das das
haben immer was gibt ja genug
Reibefläche mitnehmen
ich glaube dass die Energiepolitik nicht
falsch waren ich kann ihnen ich kann dir
nur sagen dass zwei Aspekte meiner
Meinung nach im Moment völlig
ausgeblendet werden in der Debatte das
erste ist
ein großer Teil des wirtschaftlichen
Erfolgs von Staaten wie Deutschland und
auch Österreich unsere Industrie ist
darauf zurückzuführen dass wir eine
stabile Energieversorgung hatten zu sehr
akzeptablen Energiepreisen wir erleben
jetzt gerade was ist mit Haushalten aber
auch mit ähm Unternehmen macht wenn die
Energiepreise explodieren wir sind in
Europa insbesondere in Deutschland und
in Österreich Länder mit relativ hohen
Lohnkosten
und für unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit weil
es immer immer von großen Vorteil dass
die Energiekosten relativ moderat waren
und insofern heute zu sagen es war
furchtbar dass wir aus Russland
energiebezogen haben das kann man machen
man muss aber fair genug sein dazu zu
sagen dass es schon eine Grundlage auch
unseres wirtschaftlichen Erfolgs und die
Basis für viele Arbeitsplätze in der
Industrie in Deutschland Österreich und
anderen Ländern war der zweite Punkt
wenn wir uns anschauen woher Energie Gas
Öl aber auch zum Beispiel
wenn wir in den mining Sektor denken
gewisse Rohstoffe kommen das wird im
Moment völlig ausgeklammert dann werden
Sie feststellen dass die Masse nicht aus
klassischen
westeuropäischen liberalen Demokratien
kommt sondern ganz viel in diesem
Bereich
wird nach Europa importiert aus Staaten
die nicht gerade klassische westlich
geprägte liberale Demokratien sind und
insofern kann ich Ihnen nur sagen
ist es natürlich ein Risiko gewesen dass
Deutschland und Österreich und andere im
Energiebereich die Zusammenarbeit mit
Russland gesucht haben ich sage Ihnen
nur die alternativen werden jetzt nicht
Schweden oder Frankreich oder die
Schweiz gewesen das muss man
völlig richtig
aber auch die anderen aber auch die
anderen Länder aus denen man Energie
bezieht überfallen nicht
völkerrechtswierig einen Nachbarland und
auch das ist dann eine Frage nur
abschließend ich würde die Frage ist
halt ob man bereit ist den Preis ob wir
nicht jetzt und ob nicht die Ukraine
jetzt mit ihrem eigenen Blut den Preis
für die billige Energie bezahlen die wir
lange Zeit bezogen haben das ist unterm
Strich die Frage und sozusagen die
zynische Situation der wir uns stellen
müssen wenn wir so zurückschauen
wir wollen noch über das zu dem kommen
was jetzt sozusagen
also ich finde seine spannende Debatte
ich kann Ihnen nur sagen wir können die
Debatte in Zukunft mit anderen Ländern
führen und schlicht und ergreifend die
Worte Ukraine und Russland durch andere
Staaten
austauschen ein Großteil ein Großteil
der Chip-Produktion findet außerhalb von
Europa statt ein Großteil der Rohstoffe
die wir benötigen für Batterien für
Elektroautos für Smartphones kommt nicht
aus Europäischen Union das heißt
überlegen Sie sich mal was die Zukunft
bringt wir wissen es alle nicht wie wird
sich China entwickeln wie werden sich
andere Teile der Welt entwickeln also
ich glaube im Rückspiegel jetzt zu sagen
das ist Blutgeld und das ist der Preis
den die Ukraine jetzt zahlt das kann man
machen ich sage Ihnen nur wir werden
vielleicht in fünf Jahren über eine zu
große Abhängigkeit von China sprechen
wir werden vielleicht in fünf Jahren
darüber sprechen dass viele der
Rohstoffe aus afrikanischen Ländern
kommen und wir benötigen diese Rohstoffe
dringend insbesondere für für für den
Wandel zur elektrischen Mobilität also
ich glaube es ist eine sehr verkürzte
Darstellung ich halte den Krieg für
etwas das in keiner Weise
zurechtfertigen sich als für richtig
dass es eine klare europäische Reaktion
gibt ich also für richtig dass wir
unsere Energiepolitik jetzt klarerweise
adaptieren und anpassen müssen nein
wir wollen noch über die Zukunft
sprechen
es ist in unserer Verfassung verankert
und die Neutralität war einer der
wesentlichen Bestandteile warum wir nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und nach der
Besatzung auch durch Russland unsere
Freiheit erlangt haben und insofern
glaube ich ist das etwas dass man nicht
historisch als Österreicher
berücksichtigen sollte sie sind jetzt
Unternehmer arbeiten in verschiedenen
Hinsichten aber unter anderem auch für
den umstrittenen libertär-konservativen
Unternehmer Peter Thiel ich glaube Sie
sollten sogar mal eine Rede auf ihn
halten für einen Preis in der LVZ
bekommen hat was dann kurzzeitig nicht
klappt weil sie zurücktreten mussten
jedenfalls jetzt arbeiten sie für ihn
können Sie uns ein bisschen erklären was
im Moment für jemanden machen der 2019
zum Beispiel in einem Bekannten es hier
geschrieben hat Freiheit und Demokratie
sein nicht mehr miteinander vereinbar
haben sie mit dem auch so debatten wie
wir jetzt hier heute total also ich
finde die ich finde die die Diskussionen
mit Peter till extrem bereichernd wir
haben ganz am Anfang über über sozusagen
einen meinungskorridor gesprochen und
ich finde Personen die aus diesem
ausbrechen einmal grundsätzlich extrem
interessant ja ich finde jede Debatte
mit jemanden der einen anderen Zugang
hat spannend und in einigen Bereichen
haben wir ähnliche Ansichten und den
anderen Bereichen aber unterschiedliche
Ansichten ich schätze den Peter Thiel
als jemanden der wie kaum ein anderer
Investor eine Nase dafür hat welche mega
Trends ist auf der Welt gibt und und
gleichzeitig wie sie gerade gesagt haben
einfach auch dann background ist
Philosophie also einen eine teilweise
sehr spitze Ansicht in unterschiedlichen
Bereichen einnimmt und damit auch
provoziert und gewisse Debatten Trigger
was ich persönlich gut finde was machen
sie für ihn genau ja ich kann ganz kurz
erklären was ich was ich mache ich habe
in Wahrheit mittlerweile in diesem
ersten Jahr jetzt drei Bereiche gefunden
in der nicht tätig bin das erste ist
sich mit dem kleinen Team ein
Beratungsunternehmen aufgebaut habe wo
wir unter anderem für für Peter Thiel
für sein Hedgefonds für für till capital
tätig sind für andere Unternehmen auch
wo wir teilweise in geopolitischen
Fragen
beraten und anderer andererseits nicht
für Betrieb sondern für Unternehmen
teilweise bei Business Development
Fundraising und anderen Bereichen aktiv
sind das zweite ich habe mit einem
österreichischen Partner eine kleine
Investmentgesellschaft wo wir eigenes
Geld und auch Investoren Geld
investieren und zum dritten habe ich
gemeinsam mit zwei Partnern in Tel Aviv
ein cybersicherheitsunternehmen
gegründet für den Schutz von kritischer
Infrastruktur also vor allem Energie
Elektrizität aber auch Spitäler und
anderes vom Arbeiterviertel nicht mehr
viel übrig
ich wohne noch immer dort und ich fühle
mich wohl dort die Zukunft bleibt im
unternehmerischen oder wie man hört in
Wien munkelt man das in ihrem office was
ja auch interessanterweise sehr nah an
dem Office von Herrn Blümel ist im alten
Vertrag von ihnen immer mehr ÖVP Leute
wieder ein und Ausgehen reizt sie nicht
doch zurückzukommen eigentlich nicht um
ehrlich zu sein eigentlich
ich es klingt immer so komisch wenn man
sagt man will immer in die Politik weil
das das wirkt so als würde man die
Politik negativ sehen das tue ich
überhaupt nicht und und vielleicht darum
dass das eigentlich ich habe ich habe
die Politik immer total genossen ja ich
mag den Diskurs ich habe es
unendlich genossen das Gefühl zu haben
ich kann für mein Land was beitragen ich
kann für die Bevölkerung was tun also
sozusagen es hat mir wirklich wirklich
Freude gemacht politisch tätig zu sein
aber ich habe bin 36 jetzt über zehn
Jahre in der österreichischen
Bundesregierung verbracht und daher für
mein Gefühl für mein bisheriges Leben
sehr sehr viel Zeit in der Politik
verbracht und ich finde es jetzt sehr
schön aber was Neues kennenzulernen was
anderes zu tun
auch auch sehr international unterwegs
zu sein nicht nur bei Staatsbesuchen ein
zwei Tage anders vor vorbei zu schauen
sondern dort unternehmerisch tätig zu
sein etwas zu gründen was aufzubauen mit
mit ganz unterschiedlichen Ländern aus
anderen Kulturkreisen zusammenzuarbeiten
das genieße ich im Moment sehr und daher
würde ich sagen meine Zukunft bleibt im
unternehmerischen vielleicht gelingt dem
einen einer von ihnen noch eine Antwort
darauf ich muss dazu sagen sie haben
jetzt das Glück dass ich so dieses auch
die gesamte Moderation deswegen nehme
ich mir die Freiheit etwas zu überziehen
das geht von ihrer Pause wieder ab also
das müssen sie jetzt selbst verantworten
ich sehe es viele Meldungen ich glaube
fürchte alle werden wir nicht schaffen
wir bräuchten viel mehr Zeit mit ihnen
Herr kurz aber wir nehmen vielleicht
zwei dran bitte fassen sich kurz es wäre
toll
Edgar Salzmann guten Morgen also
zunächst mal Kompliment sie haben sich
auf den heißen Stuhl gesetzt und ich
finde das richtig toll gemacht weil die
beiden haben ordentlich nachgefragt
sie wissen sie wissen nicht wie sie in
Österreich zugeht das war das war genau
da haben sie uns jetzt schwer beleidigt
gibt es eine Situation in ihrem Leben wo
sie sagen da habe ich doch mal ein
Fehler gemacht also mein Gefühl
also ein Beispiel wer hilfreich der
zweite Punkt ich glaube wir sind uns
einig das beste frei ein hohes Gut ist
und
haben wir von den Lindner noch mal
gehört meine Frage wer wie schätzen Sie
es ein in Phasen von Chris
Krisensituation hat die Presse da auch
einen Auftrag die Bevölkerung etwas
stärker mitzunehmen und wie hat die
Presse in Deutschland das jetzt in der
aktuellen Phase gemacht vielen Dank
extrem schwierige Frage die zweite also
die erste ist leicht zu den Fehlern also
dauernd ja ich fand das war das
belastendste in der in der Verantwortung
als Politiker
jeden Tag beim Aufstehen zu wissen man
wird Fehlentscheidungen treffen und
jeden Tag mit der mit dem Bewusstsein
schlafen zu gehen man hat von unzähligen
Entscheidungen einfach notgedrungen
viele wieder falsch getroffen das das
glaube ich je größer die Verantwortung
wurde desto desto mehr Bewusstsein hatte
dafür und das war das was ich immer am
belastendsten empfunden habe
spezielle Beispiele ich glaube ähm ich
glaube die schwierigste Phase war die
corona-pandemie ich glaube so richtiges
am Anfang war hart und und intensiv zu
reagieren zu sehr ist meiner Meinung
nach auf der ganzen Welt auch bei uns in
Europa bei uns in Österreich dann zu
lange zu restriktiviert worden ich
glaube es war ein ein ständiger
ein ständiges Spannungsverhältnis
zwischen
dem Versuch die Bevölkerung zu schützen
und auf der anderen Seite dem Eingriff
in Grund und Freiheitsrechte und das ist
nie eine einfache Übung also das habe
ich eigentlich in all den Jahren als am
vordersten empfunden zweite Frage extrem
schwierig wie machen das die deutschen
Medien glaube ich gibt es andere
Experten gut
so wir haben jetzt haben wir den
hessischen Ministerpräsidenten hier
schon im Raum und ich frage mich haben
wir noch Zeit für eine ganz eine ganz
kurze Frage mit der Bitte um eine
wirklich kurze Frage und kurze Antwort
alles andere wäre Ministerpräsident hat
mehr zu berichten oder wir
bitte davon ich hatte es ihnen
versprochen deswegen halte ich jetzt ja
bitte stehe ich jetzt zu meinem Wort und
dann aber bitte kurz
an
als ob es eine massive allergische
Reaktion des Systems gegeben hat
insofern wäre meine Frage
macht es Sinn so jung in der Politik zu
sein
ich glaube die Politik ist ist sollte
die Bevölkerung widerspiegeln und
insofern ist ein breiter Mix glaube ich
gut jüngere ältere Frauen Männer Leute
aus Stadt und Land also ich glaube der
Mix macht es aus
ich glaube auch nicht dass die
allergische Reaktion des Systems
aufgrund des Alters war ich glaube die
wirkliche allergische Reaktion haben wir
immer ausgelöst wenn wir versucht haben
Reformen voranzutreiben Dinge anders zu
machen oder Positionen außerhalb des
Mainstreams einzunehmen meine größte
Abtreibung habe ich bekommen als ich
2015 gewagt habe die europäische
Flüchtlingspolitik zu kritisieren und
Gemeinden ich glaube wir sollten das
Steuern und da kommen immer mehr und
mehr das kann man so nicht fortsetzen
das war die größte Abtreibung damals
in meiner ganzen politischen Karriere
insofern würde ich sagen ich glaube es
hat nicht unbedingt etwas mit dem Alter
zu tun sondern mit der Frage will mal
etwas
tritt man für etwas ein und vor allem
tritt man auch für für Meinungen eine
die vielleicht nicht immer
Mainstream sind oder 100% Zustimmung
haben
aber vielen Dank kurz vielen Dank dass
Sie sich
vielen Dank dass sich unseren Fragen
gestellt hat alles Gute
[Applaus]